Brian windhorse joining us now the ESPN
basketball writer that we see on our TV
sets I feel like almost every day oh for
sure Brian do you live out in Los
Angeles now no I come about twice a
month but I have a studio of my home
don't tell anybody perk in television
all of our insiders at NFL Network you
you haven't become an official insider
until you have they set you up inside
yeah cameras your house we have seen
Steph Curry make the extraordinary look
ordinary so many times that it doesn't
even seem extraordinary anymore if that
makes any sense did you see last night
and is there anything that that man does
that surprises you anymore well you know
he's just the right guy at the right
time you know there were there were
other times in NBA history where if you
were a 3-point shooter your coach might
have said hey we'll let you take two or
three a game but how about penetrating
and getting better shots and not only
that but just the way that he shoots the
ball he keeps sort of I know this is
gonna sound way technical but he shoots
the ball on his way up which is how you
wouldn't you know nobody ever teach
anybody to do that but it happens to be
the exact way for a guy who's a little
undersized to be a great shooter and his
personality is so wonderful and it's so
much fits on that team he's just the
right man at the right time for an era
home I mean people are gonna remember
Steph Curry there's so much when I go
across the country I don't I don't I
gotta tell you I don't see a lot of kids
you know under the age of 18 wearing
LeBron and Kobe jerseys they're all
wearing Steph Curry jerseys he is going
to inspire a generation and when we get
eight to 10 years from now we're gonna
see a bunch of kids playing into the NBA
watching Steph Curry who are shooting on
their way up because he's gonna change
the way the game is played and it's
especially last night there's no stakes
in the game it's just a Wednesday night
in the NBA and this is really what the
NBA has at this point the the the
playoffs are probably not going to have
a lot of drama unless there's a lot of
injury the Warriors are going to win
again
but what the NBA does have is night
tonight tremendous stuff it's never been
more entertaining night tonight two
nights ago Blake Griffin had 50 points
in an overtime game last night it was
tough tonight there'll be something else
and stuff you know had another wonderful
night last night can they keep it sorry
James can they keep the this team this
crew together beyond this year or just
diss klay Thompson say you know what
I've won four or whatever it'll be at
that time for him and decide to move on
I don't think it's klay Thompson I think
it's Durant that's the guy they they
would have to worry about keeping and I
just think because Durant lives in this
world where he's judged as something
less than because he joined that team
and you know I don't think that Kevin
has a weakness in his game the only
weakness that he has really is his thin
skin and his thin skin and his desire to
have his legacy not be defined as
joining the Warriors might have him look
around and you know the league change
what he went there and the league would
change again is he left I think that's
their danger they also are facing you
know if Durant were to resign and if
they were to extend a draymond Green if
they were to keep their core four
together they'd be looking at a payroll
in the neighborhood of 400 million
dollars I mean it's almost unheard of
but they actually potentially would have
the money to do it because they're about
to move in to a new arena next year that
will be the biggest cash cow building in
the world in terms of producing money so
they can afford it I just don't know if
everybody's gonna stay on the same page
and I don't really blame Durant if you
want to go elsewhere
how much do you read into that Instagram
post that his brother commented on
saying is essentially let's let's get
another one before we get out of here
yeah I don't care about that anybody
talking about okay so it's on you know I
mean and I wanted I mean one of my rules
is free agency does you know what people
think in free agency doesn't matter
until you get to the to the buzzer it's
kind of like an NBA games it's a
20-point game in the second quarter
doesn't mean it's not going to be a
buzzer beater
you would never declare any NBA game
over in the second quarter you would
never declare a free agency settled in
in October I don't I don't even care
about Kyrie Irving already announcing
he's he's going back to the Celtics
that's kind of like a player
committing to Duke will see on signing
day whether it were he's going to go so
you know so I can change whether it's
Durant's brother or Durant's agent or
Durant's best friend or Durant himself I
it more matters where things are in July
than it does now Bryan win horror song
with Dan Haley and James Coco I can see
things going through your head right now
what's popping well I guess I'd love to
ask Brian you know in terms of you
talked about his legacy Kevin Durant I
do wonder how much the outside business
ventures will play a factor as well you
know what I mean so he took a little bit
of a pay cut to play with Golden State a
lot of folks are curious well whether he
do it again because he's got so many
ventures outside of the NBA and he's
meeting so many a lot of big money out
there in the Bay Area I mean I suppose I
mean I mean that's what people say they
say oh you get it you get to be the
first person in to to invest in some of
these companies because these are all
Warriors fans and they'll give you a
chance I suppose that's true but I would
say if you go to place the New York
Knicks and you start with a New York
Knicks I don't think that you're going
to be wanting so the opportunity to do
business there are some players who have
hit the jackpot in business but in
general most of these guys wealth is
going to come from a their player
contracts and be there shoot contracts
Durant has a really great Nike contract
probably the second-best
Nike contract out there other than
LeBron and he is making 30 million
potentially more than 40 million a year
playing basketball and ultimately people
are not going to remember him for
getting in in the angel investments and
I know that that's what he does in the
offseason and I am NOT denying him that
but you know let's remember what the
main thing is here listen I don't want
to get too deep into like look into this
standings and asking about the Raptors
or the box or the Nuggets ooh by the way
I think you're gonna be a very good team
Tim Connolly he's done a great job
putting that squad together what are the
one of the two or three biggest stories
that you are going to be keeping an eye
on as we go through the season in the
Association to me there's two players
that I'm watching very closely and
they're in their teams and why is Kawhi
Leonard
I think the Raptors are awesome this is
it and I I'm very aware because I have
covered the Raptors very closely over
the last four years I'm very aware that
people have said the Raptors are awesome
in the past and then they have not been
awesome when it mattered I think this
team is a different level and I think
it's because of kowai kowai in the
conjunction of with the fact that LeBron
is no longer in the East I mean for as
much as people want to talk about the
Celtics and the 76ers both of whom I
highly respect amongst the three teams
the Raptors have the best player hmm
and the team with the best player wins a
lot of the time and you know what
happens with the Raptors and with Kawhi
again this is just gonna define a little
bit of the balance of power in the NBA
and then I looked at the New Orleans
pelicans with Anthony Davis Anthony
Davis has got it he has he's arrived
he's had his awakening he knows his
power we see this with great players at
the top of their game of the game in the
NBA sometimes it happens in their fourth
year sometimes it happens in their
eighth year Anthony Davis is in his
seventh year and he has got it he is he
is understood and he has grown basically
into an MBA adult he understands how he
manipulate games Holly can control games
how he can raise the level of games of
his teammates he has figured out in the
last year and watching him play now and
watching him lead his teammates and
figure out how to do things to take care
of his teammates and and raise his
teammates up is very rewarding to see
him graduate to that and how far this
pelicans team goes this year and if he
can carry them you know if he can do
something like get them to the
conference finals and how that will
impact
his future there both of those
situations are going to be fascinating
to watch not just for this season but
what happens in the future with both
players James ko-dan Hill here filling
in on the Rich Eisen show joined by
Brian Wynn hey Brian can you talk about
the situation there in Minnesota you
know I'm fascinated by because Jimmy
Butler obviously you know making waves
have you heard anything there in regards
to you know trades possibly and also
what kind of trickle-down effect does
that have on maybe a hot seat or does
the seat get any hotter for somebody
like Tom Thibodeau I went to the home
opener last week and I've never seen
anything like it
first off Jimmy was getting boots to
start and MVP chances yes Louder Than
then Jimmy Butler did and even though
the Wolves won the game it seems to me
that everybody on the Wolves is in a bad
mood except you me is like he's enjoying
this I mean he I talked him after the
game he's like I love being the villain
and I know that that's something people
say but I kind of think he does um you
know let's see where we if this is still
some sort of weird standoff if we get to
like late January we'll see if it's
different but I ought to tell you I've
seen a lot of things in the NBA the last
few decades I have never quite seen
something like this because yeah we see
trade demands and we'll continue to see
trade demands that ultimately will
continue to see players get their wish a
lot of times when they want to be traded
as I ultimately think at the end of the
day Jimmy Butler will be on another team
next year if not sooner but I've never
seen a guy who's willing to embrace the
fallout normally this is something that
a player has to soldier through and has
to deal with you know sort of the burden
of breaking himself free as if he's
going through some sort of gauntlet some
sort of trial
Jimmy is doing it with a smile and if
it's bothering him he's doing a
wonderful job of hiding it and it's
certainly not showing in his play who's
the most likely to end up in LA was
LeBron next year I'll have a good read
on that because the Lakers have a couple
of things going again
them in this free agency session number
one a handful of these guys who are
going to be available already have
Championships Kawhi klay Thompson
Durant they don't need to link up with
LeBron to win and that's something that
you would you know like to have in your
pocket
secondly the Laker is one of the great
advantages of being in LA is that it's
such a desirable place to be in fact I
would argue that that LA and every in
the history of the NBA has LA been more
desirable for players to live when I
first started covering the league 1516
years ago a lot of players would in
Atlanta a lot of players lived in
Orlando in Miami in New York now the
almost the entire NBA spends their
summer either in Los Angeles or in the
surrounding areas or San Diego and so
it's never been more you know been a
bigger draw but here's the thing the
Clippers are there too and the Clippers
have caps base and the Clippers are no
longer a laughingstock and both New York
teams are going to be in the market as
well both and that's index I know you'd
say well why would anybody go play for
the Nets we'll make a play for the
Lakers well you know maybe playing with
LeBron is miss desirable as it maybe was
five years ago because he's older now
and and you know there's other option so
the Lakers have to have to fight uphill
a little bit that said interesting enjoy
great advantages over just about just
about every team you know the Indiana
Pacers are going to have 35 or 40
million in cap space next year I doubt
that they're going to be able to get in
but yeah I don't think it's a guarantee
but the Lakers get a major free agent
next year and that is why them not going
after Paul George and then even with the
lesson learned having not gone Paul
George not going after Kawhi Leonard to
me is a curious decision now a year from
now they could be sitting there with
LeBron and Durant together or LeBron and
Kawhi together or LeBron and Jimmy
Butler together and we could be saying
well then waiting it out is done
fantastic because now they have both
stars and all their young players but
they've taken a significant gamble with
a guy in LeBron James who doesn't have
time
his side News Crime well then this is
the last LeBron question all I ask you
because I know that's basically your
life is LeBron on a constant basis I
contend that the move to come to LA and
not add a significant piece in this
first year tells me that LeBron is
content with knowing that he may never
win another championship and he's
thinking so much about his post
basketball career in post basketball
life that the importance of those other
things right now are almost on par with
the next four years of his basketball
career am I crazy I think he had a bunch
of flawed choices last summer
he could have stayed in Cleveland that
team has obviously sort of turned the
corner and past his prime and we have
several teams on you know rising much to
challenge them he could have gone to
Houston but there was no clean way for
him to get there and there would have
been some issues on sharing in
everything plus I don't really know if
he was all that excited about living in
Houston he could have gone to
Philadelphia where he may have been
immediately able to win a championship
but again I don't know if his family has
no connection to Philadelphia was
interested in doing that and then he
would have you know that he had Los
Angeles where his family absolutely
loves to be he had a lot of different
business opportunities but the team was
farther away than those other teams it
was all a bunch of flawed choices and so
he went with the choice that I think he
could live with not winning a
championship in which is to be in Los
Angeles and so if he doesn't win again
it will be in a other place where he can
enjoy being at the very least and
looking in the future I still think
knowing LeBron he still wants to win
he's still not conceding anything that
said I do think it's interesting that
after years after four or five years of
people trying to make Space Jam with him
he's finally going to make the movie in
the summer that it looks like he's not
going to be in the finals for the first
time in nine years I think
with his long but his outlook is
short-term for the Lakers well certainly
everything he's touching right now off
the court is turning to gold gold brine
win horse thank you so much for the time
I know time is valuable you're one of
the best in the business we really
appreciate the inside my friend take
care guys have a good day
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience